all right we're gonna change some topics
now and talk about this sunday night cbs
sunday morning anchor jane pauley will
explore the desire to live a long life
in a one-hour special on cbs it is
called forever young searching for the
fountain of youth paulie sat down with
oscar-nominated actress candice bergen
of course candice bergen is a child of
hollywood and she shared her experience
of turning 75 in an industry that is
obsessed with youth here's a preview
i just thought that if i'm going to get
older
i would like to do it with credibility
so i have these chasms on my lips and i
have a waddle which is where i wear a
turtleneck 75
just hit me
with a clump i just thought well
it was the first time that i couldn't
pretend like ah 73 is nothing but
75 was like
yeah
time to get real
and now one of my journalism icons idols
and colleagues cbs sunday morning anchor
jane pauley is joining us now jane good
morning
and good morning vlad is candice bergen
not
fabulous or what so i've been so lovely
way back since she was on when she
started on snl when she was doing snl um
you know she was very candid with you
jane about what it's like aging in
hollywood
why is that such an important topic for
her to talk about
well we talked to billy crystal as well
and both of them are uncommonly candid
for uh hollywood uh billy crystal you
know talks about um
uh uh not needing makeup to play the
older men parts that he's played all his
life he's 73
um and uh and and and still going i did
some arithmetic the oldest woman known
to have lived uh to 122
at 75 if you were to live that long
that's another 47 years
wow and the show um the special sunday
night forever young is really exploring
in many many different angles all the
ways
that clocks
run
slower
or maybe could even be reversed it's
already happened in laboratory animals
so what is the limit the outer limit of
human life
um
it's certainly not 78 years old as as
the average is uh today
it's fascinating a fascinating
thought-provoking look
yeah i'm looking forward to it
i'm starting to feel it a little bit
yeah
i have to tell you um jane i i know you
got some surprises in here you had to
have because these
they're they're so candid they're
they're also people you've covered in
the past but i'm wondering were there
surprises from either of them
uh well do you know the the the program
moves on and and uh uh we don't actually
interview the tortoise uh that had
listed
89
um you know we don't we don't ask uh the
i don't take these glasses off we don't
ask the elephants um hey how come it is
that uh you elephants don't get
we don't ask the 5 000 year old tree
that's somewhere in an undisclosed
location in california as old as the
pyramids are so what is it about
living long that are the biological
secrets that um even in pockets of
populations of human beings around the
world sardinia being one we visit where
already living to 100 is almost
commonplace
why and what if um what if we did we all
know people who you know are living long
and vital lives but um
uh uh it it
you know and why why do women live
longer than men
uh one of the reasons by the way uh that
we will learn is that women handle
stress
uh better than men do
uh which means that my husband gary is
likely to outlive me because i don't
handle stress so well
yeah i woke up at 12 47 last night in
anticipation this morning
and um got a little patchy thereafter so
um so me and you haven't
yeah jim gaffigan the the comic he's in
his 50s and um
you know and he's already that sounds
pretty old to him so you know it's
thought-provoking jane hello
i'm going to interrupt you real quickly
it's dana i because i just turned 50 and
had a really hard time admitting it but
i'm hoping that with specials like this
more of us start to realize and say like
own your age and be proud of that and
and look forward to what may be next i
know we're out of time but i just had to
say that real quickly because
it's hard
you're on the right track
yeah you're going to be around for a
whole long time with a long career
exactly in the world in the words of
karen carpenter thanks flynn
that's right well there's a whole jane
wrote that book and that's what i'm
going to check out right it's exactly
right jane paulie always so good to see
you i thank you so much for coming on we
love you thank you you can see her
special kids forever young searching for
the fountain of youth this sunday night
here on cbs and streaming on paramount
plus right now time to check
your local weather